so Jesse came to in acting class that I
have a part for that's perfect
and then what was the process like
writing the script cuz you were putting
in your own sort of flair to it whether
it's personal or imagina stories well so
he brought me the script and then I read
it and I said this is great it's very
similar to the Italian Job this means
like yeah I know I'm thinking about
reworking it and then literally nothing
happened like six months go by we sort
of do an arrow thing that was it's ready
I gave him some notes and sort of he was
doing his thing I was doing my thing and
then in class and I'm acting and I'm
doing all these scenes that were that
Millman that signed me because I was
having issues really just like owning
myself as an actor like owning like I
can do this I can have a career of sort
of frustrated with I wasn't really
breaking through and so I was on this
journey of two years of breaking through
taking really big risks as an actor and
so at the end of this period it was like
six months at the end after that thing
that with the script that I was
realizing oh man like I'm feeling really
good like I can't get a job and there
were a world like it's just not
happening and so Alan Barton who was
teaching that night had said to my scene
partner she was frustrated with her
career her sister is very famous
she felt she was better than her sister
as an actor and yet she couldn't get a
job and he said you know you've got to
build your own door and walk through it
forget her thing forget her journey
you're on your journey and so he was
talking to her but I heard it and I was
like oh man
I feel like in that moment I said I'm
worried so much about getting a casting
director to call me in or you know write
the right agent to like you know to
submit me that I should just be making
my own stuff like I hadn't been
directing and making shorts with whole
bunch of people in class and we got into
film festivals and you know we were you
know talented we had enough I knew how
to production and you had to do every
job so it was like why am I wasting my
time waiting for a casting director to
call me in a director that cast me let
me make my own thing so I went home that
night and on my whiteboard I wrote today
I stopped fighting and so my wife
Brienne who was in my girlfriend the
time I said I just feel like I'm like I
mean you know
pulling the dork out my foot in the door
and I'm like trying to get in like you
know somebody casting me and Milton used
to say you know get into the party like
however it takes to give them to the
party and so I feel like the parties
they're pulling on the door trying to
get got my foot in the door and the back
door is completely open and my friends
are there filmmakers they're like mark
come on in it's great parties great
there's free drinks is free everything
we get on drink now but I you know I was
like no I really want to get somebody
validation I need the validation from
the business before I can go into the
party and so I just let that go and then
that morning I wrote down then I can
where I wrote down three three director
writer directors that wanted to work
with me and Jesse was the first person
on the list and so I reached out to him
and said hey you know you know you had
this script and you weren't really sure
what you're gonna do with it which you
have meet me for coffee and let's just
talk and then that was sort of like so I
want to do something for myself I want
to create something you know maybe
there's a version of your script that we
can do maybe it's a short film which is
then started as talking and then we
decided that the short film was gonna be
expensive we kind of got a budget from a
friend of mine it was like $35,000 or
like just for a short film so that year
I went to Sundance with a short film
that I had acted in and there was
literally six people in the theater and
there was the four the five screenings
maybe twenty five people total I met a
ton of people at Sundance but at the
screening like there was nobody for
short film like nobody shows up those
late-night you know midnight you know
short programs but I had a friend there
that had made the movie himself feature
himself and you know it was like
$100,000 and made a deal for
international for DVD and Home Video and
was gonna make a million dollars like
over five years like all those money
who's gonna come in it's like we should
do like a feature like do it independent
and then we can sell it as a DVD we can
raise some money you know like that's
the way to go
and so as we started to work on that
then the web series our web world
started happening and I saw these web
series and they were making some you
know make him think okay looking but
they're also making money I was like
well what if we do a web series sort of
feature type of thing which is funny
because kwibi is doing that right now
that's what Katzenberg is doing with
clip it's basically short form content
that's going to be a feature which is
exactly what crackle was doing and so we
didn't know that we didn't know what we
were doing at the time we just like what
it started with we were doing a feature
expensive then we thought well there's
web series so we could do a web series
then then we thought how do we get paid
for web series and so we and then we
were trying to figure out the writing of
a web series like how long is the
episodes like is it you know can it be
long can it be sure I get everybody says
yeah be short no they'll see longer five
minutes is the longest all these
different things are like how do we you
structure a story in five minutes and
three minutes kind of thing and so it
just sort of was like a natural thing
you're like okay well if we did it as a
feature that's the you know we know act
1 act 2 act 3 and then we cut up act 1
into six parts and then eight parts for
act two six parts rag three there we've
got our series right there we've got a
web series and we got a feature film
that we can sell on DVD and home video
if we you know make money if we can you
know finish it and that was sort of the
process and so once we sort of figured
out sort of our box we also work
backwards because Jesse was like video
game guy loved playing video games I
liked cars he also like we both loved
you know sort of the conman type of
shows he'd written that and so it just
sort of as a natural thing I'm like okay
so this is the world and then we we
really we talked about this a lot is
that which is challenging at times but
we sort of knew at the time there was
even the best things we found out what
the box was like okay it's gonna be
feature it's gonna be something that we
have to be able to make it's gonna be
for eighteen to thirty-five year old
males they like video games
they like girls they like fast cars they
like you know action sequences okay
great so that's our that's our box now
we can start to fill in who these
characters that fit that box so we are
already thinking how we gonna sell it
instead of just make some cool project
you know cuz he'd already written a
script here he wrote a feature that is
hard to make so you know had like seven
minis that were you know running around
the streets of you know underneath LA
and so we can't do that we can't can't
it's too expensive so how do we kind of
create this thing and so that was the
process of us figuring out what the
world was and and then I mean the at
least is structure and then we got
together pretty much every day for six
months like in-between you know acting
auditioning classwork photography I was
doing i shooting head shots at the time
i was propping and you know getting
together every day we'd get together
with like okay from for hours at some
point we would get together we would
write we would talk about story the
world read books watch movie watch the
TV series that were similar to it and
and then but the end of that six months
we had basically a first season you know
arc we knew what the characters were we
had the pilot and really like the first
we called the pilot the first two
episodes we were splitting them up so we
had basically a principle for each I
mean again it starts building you're
like oh we can have a principle which
sort of binds these two episodes
together we can have ten episode we had
20 episodes we have ten principles one
episode he follows them second one he
doesn't anything we get to see how that
happens in each of these episodes and so
those are all things that we would get
together and figure out what pieces work
with pieces don't work and it was a lot
of work it was really a lot of work
where did you get the production budget
for this I mean cuz it's high-quality
this is not like yeah I know you said
you you look at other things you thought
well this looks more amateurish that's
not how this looks this looks incredibly
professional well yeah well what we end
up doing was we finished it in the six
months and then we sort of drank the
kool-aid thinking oh what people are
gonna love this thing and like they're
gonna buy this and we're gonna be able
to put together you know business
proposition we could put a whole
proposal together we got budgets we got
this whole thing we started meeting
people some private investors some big
agencies
everybody passed every was like us wait
too expensive like nobody's gonna make a
web series for this money and you know
it's just I think it was like I think we
had heard that somebody would make an
episode for $50,000 in episode I think
so we put that number down and then and
then once we got sort of six months of
like doing that we're like it's not
gonna work like no one wants to buy this
thing is just too expensive they like
the idea but it was just too high
concept for the places that we're making
webseries at the time and so we said
well we were both depressed well usually
we were one of us were up in one of us
down but we were bolstered the press at
that time we were both like he just hit
again a wall you know where you know a
guy an agent at ICM that said to us you
know it's like no offense mark but
you're not Clooney and you're not so de
Burgh so no one's gonna like just give
you guys all this money so we're both
depressed I'm in Atlanta shooting some
photos for a magazine and that just hit
me it's like why we should make it
ourselves look let's go we shoot the
first two episodes there's like a pilot
and then we can show is like a proof of
concept then we can cut a trailer and we
can you know get it to some people
because right now they didn't think we
could do it for little or money then you
know instead of it being like a three
million dollar thing so we did we put
together what that would look like put a
budget for those two episodes and you
know and Jessie's wife was very
successful and was like I'll help you
guys support and listen figure out how
we're gonna make this so we put down the
money together we figured out how we're
gonna make it I think it was like twelve
thousand dollars we put together for
this you know three days shoot and if we
got a car from Jaguar like I reached out
to them I got this car so we shot this
episode these two episodes cut it
together and cut a trailer together and
then we had started putting it together
a website which is basically like now
would be like a pitch deck for the
series but as a website so since we
thought it was gonna be a webseries it's
gonna be on the web we created a website
we had like the character page we had
like the world we had you know what the
synopsis was with the what the season
one arc is how we get brand it how the
brands can come in and you
now you know that being there from the
car to close
sunglasses to all these different things
and we put the trailer up and we send
this out to like that email list that
you were talking about and at the time
you know I had maybe you know 250 people
he had maybe 250 people and we sent that
out and said this is what we've been
working on here's the trailer we're
still working on two episodes but you
know if you know anybody that might you
know be able to help us get this made
let us know first call I got it was like
20 minutes after we sent the email and
it was ICM assistant calling for my
friend Jesse Albert and so I called
Jesse and this is the guy that said I'm
not cleaning and he's not soda Burke and
he said this is great like this is great
he's like I'm on my way to NBC right now
can I pitch it to him I was like wait
what Wow I was like yeah yeah yes and
then he came back and he said they loved
it and can I pitch it to crackle
tomorrow they're looking for basically
what you guys have which is his web
series slash feature film and and that
began our thing so we Bissell met all
the studios in town love the networks
and crackle to seem that means a they
got us they figured out they they got us
as creators they believed in the project
and they had no problem that I wasn't
Clooney and he wasn't sober baby you're
perfect we don't want to recast no
you're perfect and other people were
like were you open to having other
people you know potentially and we said
no he's directing I'm in it that's
that's how it goes and so between NBC
Universal and crackle and we end up
going with crackle just felt like that
was like the best home for us and and so
that's why it looks so great is that we
end up you know pitch it to them several
meetings we got like okay they're sure
they want to do it they want to budget
now we'd already gone through budgets of
stuff and we're like okay he said if you
can make it for this money they'll say
yes so that's what the our agent told us
so we knew the number and now basically
we try to fit and we said okay we can do
for that number we talked to a friend
and put together budget she's like yeah
that's a lot of money for what you guys
are doing I mean it's not like a lot but
like
yeah we can do that so we said here's
the number and they said that's great
that's what we can do and so six months
later of negotiating it's the same deal
the same thing and we we got the green
lights you start writing it because we
had basically six episodes written we
had the first season but we hadn't
written the whole thing out and they
were glad they did because they wanted
to be able to work with us on sort of
the the idea and and so we worked
another five or six months on the
scripts with them getting it to where
they said they kept saying just don't
worry about budget just like just write
this group write the best movie and so
it was like a you know a process of us
doing a draft getting a budget having
been three times more than the budget we
said we can make it four and I'm saying
it's too expensive
so rewrite it and so we were constantly
going back to rewriting it getting a new
budget rewriting and getting a new
budget and finally we got to the point
where they were like there's no more
money than what you said you can make it
four so like let's make it four this and
it was just such it was a heartbreaking
thing because at first they're saying
make whatever you make it and then
somebody kept saying in there there's
more money don't worry about there's
more money but there wasn't it was like
that was the money that we said we can
make it for cuz just he told us didn't
say that and we didn't know any better
and it's not that he's wrong I mean that
was the number they were looking forward
to greenlight a project what year was
this sorry to interrupt this was 2009 ah
okay do you think if it had been 1999
and we had web series then it would have
been different do you think that the
downturn had anything to do with
definitely a downturn definitely yeah
yeah it was at that point it was like
they were so trying to cut their losses
and figure out how to do stuff that
everybody was like uh-huh let's not make
too how do we gonna recoup our money on
this and crackle was just starting out
with they'd only done one others show
previously that was basically a feature
they cut up but it wasn't made that
ready originally but they realized oh
that works we can do these short form
kind of things yeah but it was a totally
different world I mean even like I would
say five years later was even harder for
them I have had friends that had
projects
at crackle that we're trying to get
things made and became harder to you
know not even a lot more money to do it
was like there's a little bit more money
than we had for Bannon but it was like
still tough til I get things may cuz
everybody wants like can you just make
it for less you make it for lastingly if
that's what everybody mean that's what
producers and Studios want to do because
they need a profit but as challenging as
a creative to go you're trying to you
know we had created this box that we
thought and then they just said oh don't
worry about the box
like it can be whatever you want it to
be and then we realized oh no that was
not we I don't even think we heard that
correctly
you know when they said don't worry
about budget I think they meant like
right the best movie and we'll trim
where we need to trim you know we have
hard core people we had like you know 12
parkour guys like climbing buildings is
like no we can't do that
you